Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the 2015 Drama
Sci-Fi short film called “Getting Fat In
A Healthy Way.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts as a fat man and his lean
wife are outdoors with their child, Constantine,
for a dry picnic.
While they are swinging Constantine on their
hands happily, the wife notices a towel flying
to the sky.
Suddenly, the gravity stops working at once.
Everything except for the fat man starts floating
up to the sky.
The wife and the boy also start floating up.
The fat man grabs his son, and the son’s
hand is chained with his mother's in the air.
However, the mother puts on a good-bye face
and relinquishes her son’s hand in the air.
Devastated, the fat man is in utter disbelief
as his wife flies high in the sky.
As he pulls his son and hugs him tightly,
he wakes up from his dream with a heavy breath.
This is a true incident that Constantine’s
father faced 20 years ago after the earth’s
gravity and the moon’s shape were affected
by a devastating American aircraft accident.
Due to the accident, the world entered a dystopia
where anything weighing less than 120 kilograms
flies up in space.
Next, we get a view of the disturbing shape
of the moon above a set of apartments.
Constantine and his father are having their
food in the kitchen.
The table is attached to the wall through
a bracket and a gravity meter is working inside
the house, making sure everything is in check.
The bookshelf is also seen caged with a fence.
A man on television talks about the day being
the marking of the 20th anniversary of the
unfortunate mission of the American shuttle
NEW LAND.
He informs that the anniversary of the accident
falls on the full moon and alerts that there
are high chances of damage to the naked eye.
As the TV man asks all the viewers to maintain
a minute of silence for the memory of those
who perished in the accident, a large sound
is heard in the room, which shocks the father-son
duo.
Soon, the plates and the food start flying
to the ceiling.
Constantine struggles to hold his hand on
the table while his body floats in the air.
Despite his best efforts, he loses his grip
and rises to the ceiling in an instant.
Constantine’s father curses the fuses and
goes to the Gravity machine.
He rotates a knob and alerts Constantine that
he is going to switch on the machine.
As Constantine closes his eyes and prepares
for the fall, the machine starts.
The father covers his head with his hands
as the pieces of stuff flown to the ceiling
start falling.
Constantine cries in pain as he thuds to the
ground.
The father then puts a photo of his wife back
on the wall.
He asks if Constantine is alright, while Constantine
checks his aching body.
Later, Constantine’s father checks his weight
in the weighing machine and discovers it to
be a little more than 120 kg.
He gets worried that if his weight drops to
less than 120 kg, he will become helpless
like his son.
Then, he carries a spherical metal ball marking
20 kg in his bag.
He informs Constantine that the coffee is
on the table as he flies to work.
As Constantine is always behind four walls
for his lesser weight, he takes a binocular
and watches through the window to the streets.
He finds a man in a military uniform holding
a floating bag with his hand.
He then sees his father talking to two fat
women who are apparently walking their dogs
on floating leashes.
At the other apartment, he notices a woman
throwing a musical instrument at a man on
the ground but it floats back to her again.
One of the women on the street starts gossiping
about Constantine’s father torturing Constantine
for not letting him out.
She suggests that he can come out with a rope
tied to him.
As they talk, their floating dogs bark louder.
Tired of being at home and envious of the
fact that he can’t go out, Constantine tries
his best to live a normal life.
He plays a cassette of the sea with the sounds
of waves.
He then opens up an umbrella and covers the
sofa with it.
He focuses the light on one of the sofas.
He undresses his layers of clothes and the
pillow from his body, which he uses to shield
his body against the gravity fluctuations.
He then puts on the sunglasses, lotion and
starts sunbathing.
Later, Constantine gets up and goes to the
window after hearing the honking of a vehicle.
A cute and chubby lady walks out of the vehicle
and looks up.
As Constantine gazes at her through the binoculars,
she unties her hair which flies up and she
waves her hand at him.
Constantine immediately feels shy as he hasn’t
had any interaction with women since birth.
He puts on his clothes along with his pillow
and writes down ‘Hello’ on a chart.
He then stands up to show it to her but backs
out at the final moment.
After his father arrives home from work, Constantine
serves him food that he cooked.
His father notices the apron and tells him
that it is for women.
Constantine replies that it is unisexual.
The father exclaims it belonged to his mother
and suggests he put it back in its place.
Constantine obliges and then returns to his
table.
The father again checks his weight in the
machine again before heading out.
He sighs with frustration as it gets nearer
to 120 kg.
Constantine peeps through the door hole and
confirms his father has gone.
Then, he collects the adult magazines and
selects one of them.
Constantine covers himself with the blankets
to dive into the excitement.
He imagines the girl from the van playing
swing.
Suddenly, Constantine gets disturbed as the
magazine falls to the ground with a sound.
He picks it up and finds the page titled “Getting
fat in a healthy way.”
He looks at the advertisement of the Burger
which states that with good food, one can
easily gain 120-kg weight.
After the advertisement convinces him, Constantine
orders a huge number of burgers and starts
having them.
After eating, he checks his weight and becomes
happy at finding it to be more than 60 kg.
Meanwhile, he hears the vehicle honking and
quickly writes his name on the chart paper.
As the girl of his dreams walks down the vehicle,
he shows the chart through the window glass.
The girl looks at it and waves her hand to
Constantine.
After his magical encounter, Constantine starts
finishing his remaining burgers.
Despite having difficulty in swallowing them,
he does not give up.
He pushes the burgers down his stomach and
finally finishes them off.
Soon, he feels uncomfortable.
The father receives a phone call stating that
Constantine has suffered from food poisoning.
He hurries home quickly.
As he arrives, he sees Constantine sick in
his bed while the medical personnel prepare
to leave.
Later at the kitchen, Constantine finds a
note written by his father over the fridge
which states not to forget his promise while
his father is flying to work.
Constantine checks his weight and gets disgusted
at finding it to be around 50 kg.
He puts some pillows inside his dress and
sits to write something in the chart, dedicating
it to the girl.
Down, the girl looks at Constantine’s room
but doesn't find him there.
Frustrated by his life, Constantine tries
his best to go out.
He binds himself with a fridge and pushes
it hard to make it to the door.
As he is about to leave, his father enters
the house back from the office.
He pushes the fridge back to the room with
Constantine still over it.
The father then transports all the machines
and heavy equipment from the room, as a precaution.
Constantine gets annoyed upon not being able
to express his love to the girl.
The father comes into his room and finds everything
torn and thrown to the ground.
He goes back to his room and sits at his table
to work on a pair of shoes.
After working, he falls asleep in the chair.
He dreams of his son leaving the grasp of
his hand and flying up the sky.
His eyes open with shock on seeing this.
When he wakes, he finds his wife’s photos
and other small stuff stuck in the ceiling
due to the faulty fuse of the gravity machine.
However, he notices that the shoes did not
fly up.
He throws them from a height and notices them
falling downwards.
The father then switches on the gravity machine
and everything stuck to the ceiling falls
to his head.
When Constantine comes to the kitchen the
next day, the father brings the pair of shoes
and puts them on the table.
Constantine comments that they are ladies’
shoes.
The father replies that the shoes are unisexual.
Constantine slowly puts on the shoes and carries
a bag of metallic weights, while his father
looks on proudly.
He then turns the Gravity machine off.
But this time Constantine doesn’t float,
which makes both of them happy.
Constantine then moves to the ground outside
the apartment with the shoes and bags on.
His father watches him from the window.
He heads towards the apartment ahead.
The girl from the van is watching him from
the balcony of her room.
He reaches below her apartment and looks at
her up.
All of a sudden, he shuts off the power of
the shoes, despite his father screaming not
to do so.
Constantine then throws his bag away and takes
out the pillow from his body too.
He closes his eyes and keeps on rising upward.
However, he feels someone’s hand grasping
his shoulder and not letting him go any higher.
Constantine smiles as he sees the girl he
loves in front of her smiling back at him.
After watching the events unfold, Constantine’s
father winks at the photo of his wife.
At the end of the movie, the radio floats
up in the sky.
The man on the radio welcomes their surprise
guest, an American astronaut ‘Dusan Pradic',
and asks him to say a few words.
The astronaut who was also a part of the fatal
accident, starts with an apology.
He then announces that the world will probably
never recover from the dystopia they put into.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.